So we said one of the biggest problems
with K means is that it was really
sensitive to, sort of needing to
know how many clusters there were,
what K was, and also possibly to the
initial conditions, that you gave it.
So the assumption of K means is that
there are essentially these spherical
clumps within feature space.
So if you're thinking of these
as a probability distribution,
it is that there would be a couple of
modes, peaks, in our features space
that, and sort of falling, nearby
those peaks is a sort of fall off, and
that our pixel intensities are
distributed according to a probability
density function that has these modes.
So if you could find the modes,
you might be able to
segment the image that way.
So, the approach that we
are going to talk about for
doing that is called the mean
shift algorithm, and
we actually introduced this when
we were talking about tracking.
It's a little bit easier to talk about
that when we do it as a cluster.
So the mean shift algorithm was designed
as a way of finding these modes,
or these local maxima of density,
in some feature spaces.
So here, by the way, this,
this is a beautiful, pastel image of,
these houses, as the input image, and
what we have here on the right is
the plotting of each of these pixels
in the L u v color space.
You remember L u v color?
This is why we're doing this
whole conversation after,
we talked about color.
Because if I told you L u v and
you hadn't heard it and think I was
doing RGB, no it's L u v, right?
And you can imagine right away,
that looking at a picture like this,
the color, the chroma, is what matters,
and the absolute intensity
might matter less, right?
Because the, so let's see,
using this yellow here.
So this is a brighter yellow,
and this is a darker yellow,
but I would like to have them both
be in the same color segment.
So L u v makes that easier.